President Trump gives conan the
terrorists chomping canine killing
machine a plaque and a medal at the
White House on the same day that he
signs sweeping federal animal cruelty
legislation and while Conan is the
goodest boy in the country the law is
very bad we will examine our broken
moral compass then speaking of
controversial opinions an American
professor receives international scorn
for offering an unpopular opinion on
Indian cuisine and the whole absurd
episode actually has a lot to teach us
about gratitude two days before
Thanksgiving
a news outlet Prince news that looks bad
for Republicans only to delete the story
when it turns out the news is bad for
Democrats and finally the campaign
manager for the latest twenty20
Democratic presidential entrant says
Trump is headed for victory in 2020 all
that and more on Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
I got a spicy take I have a very spicy
controversial opinion you think that
Indian food is spicy you think that the
Indian food guy has a controversial
opinion I have a more controversial
opinion and it has to do with animals
but I'm right yesterday was animal day
at the White House they invited Conan
that terrorists killing dog that was
great that was the great part of the day
and then President Trump signed this new
sweeping federal legislation that was
the not-so-great part of the day let's
start with the great part let's start
with Conan the dog president Trump walks
out he's in the Rose Garden he's got
that little abu-bakr chomping machine
next to him and he talks about what a
great dog he is and how he won a medal
which by the way I sort of feel we memed
into existence when we posted that that
internet meme and that image of Conan
getting the the medal of pawner around
his neck now we are in reality because I
don't know I guess we're living in the
matrix or something we're just causing
things to cut flow in and out of
consciousness in reality
President Trump in the Rose Garden gives
Conan his due so this is a comment right
now probably the world's most famous dog
I don't think I have to use the word
probably
and Conan is a incredible it's an
incredible story I learned a lot about
this particular type of dog and it's
it's train that if you open your mouths
you will be attacked you want to be very
very careful but Conan came over from
the Middle East just arrived with some
of the great people from the special
forces that did the incredible floor it
was a flawless attack and al Baghdadi's
gun but that was a flawless attack and I
just spent quite a few of them and we
just gave Conan a medal and a plaque and
it's really and I actually think Conan
knew exactly what was going on but a dog
that is very very special all right
I love this whole little ceremony I love
the dog because every image every video
of the dog he just looks so happy
he's smile and he's got his tongue
hanging out and I love the idea that
he's there just thinking oh boy I can't
wait to eat another terrorist oh boy so
he's just it's a perfect image he looks
great
you got Mike Pence just leaning down
scratching him like he's a little poodle
even though he's obviously this just
lean mean a killing machine
I also love the ceremony because it it
treats animals in the way that animals
should be treated you should love
animals you should enjoy animals the
pets are there for our enjoyment to be
treated like a member of the family
because the the pet is you know in a way
an extension of our humanity so really
look are we really giving credit to this
dog for killing the terrorists no we're
gonna give credit to the Special Forces
team that went in there and actually
executed the operation but president
Trump can't go out and honor these
soldiers you know on their on their own
I mean frankly if he if he gives away
their identity that would put them in
great danger and it would appear that
they're still working anyway it would
appear that they're still over in the
Middle East so instead what he's doing
is using the dog as a symbol of the
whole team and saying we're gonna honor
this dog and really we're honoring the
whole team it actually ties in pretty
well with what happened later in the day
on the animal
which is the animal cruelty legislation
except that unfortunately President
Trump and even a lot of conservatives
really are getting this this whole issue
backwards and this animal cruelty
legislation is actually a pretty bad law
we'll get to that in a second but first
I got to thank our friends over at
Ashford University a master's degree can
make a big difference
in anybody's career okay it means better
jobs it means more advancement a
master's degree can Cal help you be a
whole new you and now is the best time
to make it happen with help from Ashford
University we talk all the time on this
show about how the kind of stale old
university system is decaying all around
us and there are some incredible
innovative partners that we have out
there like Ashford University who are
really mixing up and making a work for
you it's convenient and flexible Ashford
University's online master's degree
programs allow you to earn at your own
pay
earn your degree and learn for your
degree at your own pace you can study
wherever you are the most comfortable
learning you can do it on your own time
you could be working you take one course
at a time
Ashford University is six-week long
courses allow you to take one course at
a time and being enrolled in one class
at Ashford means that you are considered
a full time student how do you enroll
it's easy
you got the GRE the GMAT and other
standardized test scores are not
required to enroll at Ashford University
and accreditation Ashford University is
fully accredited by the W ASC senior
college and university commission if
you're looking to make a change if you
feel stalled out in your career this
might be the way to move ahead Ashford
University new opportunities are right
around the corner now is the time to
start earning your master's degree in
role now by going to Ashford dot edu
slash Noel's came to wles that is
Ashford dot edu slash Noel's canna wles
to start your master's degree today
Ashford edu / Knowles so when you look
at at conan when you look at kona in the
this barbarian animal that eats the
terrorists
part of the reason we love him is
because we've kind of brought him in
right we've brought him in not just into
this Special Forces team but into the
consciousness of the country we like
that he's part of the team and he really
did do a job out there in the team it
reminds me of what CS Lewis said about
animal cruelty laws and animal cruelty
just as a as a topic and emotive
behavior he animal cruelty is terrible
it's an awful awful thing but it's awful
because it deadens our humanity because
it makes us cruel it's it's awful
because of what it does to human beings
you can't sin against an animal or
against a tree or against an inanimate
object you can't commit a sin against
them human beings are the moral
creatures on this earth there is a very
modern idea that animal cruelty is wrong
because animals have some kind of rights
now I say that animals have human rights
animals cannot have human rights because
they're not humans there's a gorilla or
so there's some kind of monkey that is
living in Florida that is considered a
nonhuman person but yeah the monkey
can't be a person because the monkey is
not a human nothing about that would
ever excuse animal cruelty but it shows
you where your moral compass has to be
guided toward human beings are the moral
agents on earth we shouldn't be cruel to
animals because it deadens our humanity
we should be caring and loving to
animals because it expands our humanity
a lot of people miss this unfortunately
it would appear including president
Trump so later on in the day he signed a
federal law
brand-new federal law banning animal
cruelty so it's taking animal cruelty
even from the state level all the way up
to the federal level he couldn't be
happier and so many conservatives are
cheering him on thank you all for being
here today I'm pleased to sign the
preventing animal cruelty and torture
Act into law animal cruelty this is
something that should have happened a
long time ago and it didn't but the
people
behind me and others have been
incredible and I just want to
congratulate you and I is the same
question I asked for another bill that
we just said why I said that this
happened a long time ago can I give you
the same answer because Trump was
impressive this common-sense legislation
restricts the creation distribution of
videos or images of animal torture it is
important that we combat these heinous
and sadistic acts of cruelty which are
totally unacceptable in a civilized
society we're pleased to be joined by
some of the very important people that
got this done and they worked very very
hard on it
okay what's the law do President Trump
just told you it makes a federal crime
out of certain animal torture and what
it builds upon is a law from the Obama
administration that specifically looked
at these really sadistic videos that
were going around the internet
I guess they pertained to different
sexual fetishes where people would step
on animals and crush the the animals and
so this became illegal and it actually
was a case that went all the way up to
the Supreme Court and now this law is
expanding that in making more forms of
animal cruelty illegal at the federal
level it would appear that Laura Trump
who is president from slaughterin law
has been really pushing this Laura Trump
came out with a number of statements
about about this law she said our
companion pets our family members and
our working dogs are our heroes there's
a democratic representative from Florida
who is a co-sponsor of this law he said
that the torture of innocent animals is
abhorrent of course and should be
punished to the fullest extent of the
law sure signing this bill into law is a
significant milestone for pet owners and
animal lovers across this country okay
yes animal cruelty is very bad it should
be illegal people who do it should be
punished nevertheless this is an
extremely stupid idea this is an
extremely stupid law the whole episode
reveals two distressing facts people
don't know how our government works and
people don't know how the moral order
works so let's start with the government
before we get to the actual
human level of this the actual morale
actually moral order level of this at
the government level
why should animal cruelty be a federal
offense
why well because it's really serious
that's it would appear to be what
everyone who's sponsoring this bill says
animal cruelty is so abhorrent it's so
bad that it needs to be punished at the
highest possible level and in people's
minds what this means is it needs to be
punished at the federal level for the
federal government they don't understand
that we have a federal system meaning
the federal government the states local
government municipalities to put this in
perspective most murders are tried and
punished at the state level murders of
human beings so you're telling me that I
can murder a human being in cold blood
that can be handled by the state the
state is sufficient to deal with that
but if I abuse an animal if I abuse a
little puppy or something that has to be
a federal offense the state can't
possibly handle that they can only
handle it when you murder in human
beings but when you abuse a little puppy
that has to be handled by the federal
government because that is so much more
serious now when you put it in those
terms
nobody would agree with that nobody
would think that you should make a
federal offense out of animal cruelty
but let murders be handled at the state
level if really the difference here is
about the severity of the crime
but it's not the question that I have to
ask of the people who think that this is
so important it must be handled at the
federal level is what makes you think
that the federal government is more
capable of handling this than the state
government what makes you think that a
more distant government that's less
accountable to you is going to be better
at handling these matters than the more
local government I do believe that most
people in America now think that way
most people think that yes federal
government bigger better that's that's
where we've got to put the important
issues that's certainly not how the
founders of our country thought that is
certainly not the idea that has allowed
our country to develop for the past 200
years 250 years at this point we've
always thought that more
government is better able better
equipped to deal with most problems and
you reserved only a handful of offenses
for the federal government well so much
for that so much for that constitution
order but then think about it simply as
a question of the moral law how is it in
this country that if you kill a baby at
virtually any stage of development
virtually anywhere you get off scot-free
it's your right to do that the left in
this country will applaud you for
exercising your rights kill a human
being a human baby get off scot-free
if you murder another person you murder
your neighbor that's a state crime but
you abuse an animal anything from a
kitten to a puppy to a goldfish that's a
federal offense
that's a pourraient not even saying you
kill it you just abuse it that is the
worst thing you could possibly do it
seems to me we've lost track of our
priorities we need to get our priorities
in better order I see it all around LA
the way that puppies are treated is
better than the way that humans are
treated people in LA are absolutely
cruel to one another this is really
tough down okay and but it's true of
other towns too it's true in Washington
DC for example but you see the way that
people treat one another and they use
one another they throw people away like
it's nothing and yet they put their
little miniature poodle in a spammy
stroller and bring them in to every
single restaurant and order them foie
gras half the time that is an inversion
of the natural order and certainly of
the moral order do you remember this was
a year or two ago at Coachella a video
went around of a woman in a Jeep she
gets out of her Jeep she's got a bag and
she walks up to a trash bin and she
throws out this bag and what people
found out is pretty disturbing found out
that there were puppies in the living
puppies in the baggage just threw out
the puppies right absolutely a sociopath
crazy awful woman and when this one
became a public matter it went totally
viral and people wanted to adopt the
little puppies how could you ever do
this what kind of cruel monster would
ever tolerate a woman throwing out a bag
of puppies meanwhile just a few years
ago Kermit Gosnell the worst mass killer
in American history an abortionist who
was operating with the blessing I use
that word ironically the blessing of the
left in Philadelphia nationally Kermit
Gosnell had bags of babies all over his
apartment all over his house and nothing
no outrage the media doesn't cover it
nobody wants to hear about it nobody
wants to adopt those babies they want to
enshrine it as a right the left right
now is praying to whatever God they have
I guess Moloch or ball or Baphomet or
something they're praying that Ruth
Bader Ginsburg and 86 year old jurist
doesn't die before Trump is out of
office because they need they're so
desperate to preserve the right to
murder a million babies a year so we
weep over bags of puppies we weep over
animal cruelty and we are completely
dead to the suffering of human beings
come this is absolutely backwards and I
think people are trying to separate this
as a dichotomy like you can only be kind
to animals or you can only be kind to
humans but the way it actually works is
if you get the natural order right if
you get the moral order right if you
look with charity on your fellow man if
you treat your neighbor as yourself you
will be kind to animals and everything
else you'll be a good steward of your
environment you will you'll get things
in order but if you disregard your
fellow humans and you you only love
sentimental saccharine things like
little animals or something you will not
be kind to human beings because you're
perverting you're inverting that natural
order that is not the recipe for a good
society all right right now what what so
much of this animal legislation is about
is just about saccharine soft soap
sweet feelings right it's just about
emotion we love the little puppy the
little puppy looks cute little puppy
looks like baby Yoda okay and you so you
want to just do whatever you can for the
little puppy self government doesn't
operate very well when it's purely on
emotion we need to have some logic we
need to have some objective reality and
and the way to do that is to care about
your fellow humans to get your
priorities in order mother Teresa gave a
speech at the UN in 1994 on abortion she
said abortion is the greatest cause of
evil in the world because if a mother
can kill her own baby then there is
nothing that we won't do to one another
there is no way to teach people not to
be violent and to love one another and
the way that the left wants to put a
band-aid over this horrific tact that
they're sanctioning is by saying sure
we'll kill a million babies a year but
we really like this puppy so we're gonna
pass a law about this puppy no dumb
forget about that get your moral order
in perspective before you can move on to
those sorts of things here's another
spicy take on a completely separate
issue and the pun is very much intended
this is one of these stories that seems
incredibly dumb but it's actually
telling us a lot about our culture this
is a story that was going around the
internet yesterday an American professor
was asked to tweet out a controversial
food opinion this was a hashtag of trend
going around tweet out your
controversial food opinion so this
american professor tom nichols professor
at the US Naval War College in the
Harvard Extension school tweeted out
quote Indian food is terrible and we
pretend it isn't I actually like Indian
food I disagree with him on this opinion
but hey look he knew that this is a
controversial opinion that's why he
responded to the controversial opinion
tweet right so he says Indian food is
terrible and we pretend that it isn't
all hell broke loose not only did he get
ratioed 16,000 replies to 2,000 retweets
this became an international incident
this got international media coverage
the BBC posts quote Indian food is
terrible tweet sparks hot debate about
racism racism has having to do with
racism
the eater magazine says quote
controversial food opinions prompt on
Twitter motivated racist comments it's
racist if I don't like Indian food
that's racist now what if I don't like
Chinese food I love Chinese food
obviously but is that that's racist if I
don't like that Sonya Gupta who is some
person with a lot of Twitter followers
that could describe so many people in
the media today she tweeted out quote
white people dunking on Indian food
sucks but white people fawning over it
sucks too it's the same feeling I had as
a kid when white women would fawn over
my mom's beautiful saris while also
talking to her as if she was a child you
like our trappings but you don't like us
like my mentions are filling up with
white people who were enthusiastic about
my food where is your enthusiasm for my
humanity just wondering this woman
doesn't have enough problems this woman
needs more problems I mean I don't mean
that flippantly I mean she actually
needs to have more problems if she wants
to be able to develop as a human being
suffering does help us it helps us to
mature and it deepens our view of
society this woman needs problems okay
because if she's upset about this if
she's upset that that white people like
Indian food she has lived simply too
luxurious a life what does this tell us
what this very surface level stupid
story tells us about the culture a few
things shows us some people want to be
angry they just want to be angry they
they're begging to they go and look for
a Twitter thread called controversial
food opinions just so that they can find
something they disagree with just so
they can be angry because some people
want to be aggrieved and some people
really want to be offended and there's
no arguing with those people there's no
you might maybe you've seen it if you've
watched any of my campus lectures now in
in recent months I'll go and I'll give a
speech that's like pretty innocuous and
the students won't know what to protest
in the speech so they won't literally
set a timer and then 10 or 11 minutes in
they will all stand up and start
screaming at me about what I have no
idea they'll start screaming and I've
asked them I said what are you offended
about let's talk about it
they don't have anything to say they
just want to be offended I don't know
what it is if you think about some of
the psychobabble maybe they just really
don't like their dad's or something if
you think about it from a an academic
perspective I don't know maybe they just
haven't learned a lot some people want
to be offended some people want to be
aggrieved there is no arguing with those
people
nothing is never nothing is ever enough
for them here's another example Jeff
Bezos just donated 98.5 million dollars
to help the homeless almost a hundred
million dollars to help the homeless
there is no way to be upset about this
right oh you're wrong you're not living
in 2019 Jeremy Corbyn who is the leftist
leader in Britain tweeted out quote
that's zero point zero nine percent of
your net worth Jeff Bezos just pay your
taxes by the way he does pay his taxes
there was a few years ago Amazon was
reinvesting money in their business so
they didn't pay a lot of taxes they pay
a lot of taxes now also how much money
has Jeremy Corbyn ever given to the
homeless but first of all how much money
is Jeremy Corbyn ever paid in taxes not
a lot of it how much money is he ever
given to the homeless less than one
hundred million dollars yeah I would bet
so before you accused me take a look at
yourself buddy ask yourself this
question how much money did you give to
charity this year most likely if you're
listening to this show you're not one of
these people who scream and yell at
everyone else for things that they did
or didn't do but if you are if somehow
someone I'm on Twitter and the Twitter
world is watching or listening to this
how much money did you give to charity
yourself
most people don't give a lot of money to
charity most people don't even think
about it
but the secret is you're not going to
miss that money what this brings up from
the Indian food story to Jeff Bezos what
this all brings up
at a deeper cultural level is that there
are two ways of looking at the world and
this is very important when you were two
days away from Thanksgiving two ways of
looking at the world one from a position
of entitlement one from a position of
gratitude if you are looking at the
world from a position of entitlement you
are most likely going to look at
politics primarily as a matter of Rights
you're going to see every little slight
that was ever done to you you're going
to imagine completely imagine new
slights committed against you like that
Indian woman who says that she doesn't
like the white people like Indian food
you're going to judge others by their
actions and you're gonna judge yourself
by your intentions you are going to
hoard rather than to give you are going
to be miserable how about the flipside
if you look at life primarily from a
attitude of gratitude you were going to
look at politics primarily as a matter
of duty not of Rights ask not what your
country can do for you but what you can
do for your country
you are going to forgive slights against
you you might not even notice half of
them you are not going to sit around
imagining new slights you're gonna be
happy for the life that you have you are
going to give people a break and you're
going to be thankful that you don't get
called out on all of the terrible things
that you do you are going to give freely
you were going to be much happier
because you are going to realize that
you did not invent your life you are not
responsible for giving yourself your own
life life was a gift you should be very
happy to have it something to think
about as we move into Thanksgiving and I
would recommend at least for the
Thanksgiving meal turning off Twitter
turn it off you don't you don't need
during that moment to imagine all of the
new grievances against you you don't
need to sit there and and try to figure
out a way to be offended obviously I'm
preaching to the choir here but when
you're having Thanksgiving dinner with
your leftist relatives maybe you could
gently suggest that to them as well a
big story coming out of the mainstream
media turns out they're liars I know
you'll be shocked plus the newest
presidential candidate in the race seems
to have good news for president Trump as
does the Supreme Court as good news for
president Trump too we'll get to
of that and more but first I've gotta
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube head
on over to daily wire.com daily wire.com
it's ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership what do you get you
get me get the and reclaim and show you
get the Matt Walsh show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get another Kingdom
this is the third and final season of
another Kingdom I did a 45-minute
interview yesterday with drew answering
subscriber questions about another
Kingdom we love it I mean this is such a
been such a joy to work on that we
always talk about how conservatives need
to be in the culture well here we are go
give it a listen
you get everything you get the leftist
tears tumblr this is going to be very
very important when we get some new
information about the 2020 presidential
race we get some new information about
impeachment make sure to go get that
tumblr go to daily wire comm we'll be
back with a lot more
alright there was a story that came out
from AFP from the the news outlet AFP
news agency this came out at a week ago
first tweet hashtag breaking breaking
news more than 100,000 children in
migration related u.s. detention
according to the UN 100,000 children
that's bad no matter what you think
about immigration that's pretty bad
obviously you want to deal with that how
do you deal with that the left wants to
deal with that by just getting rid of
our borders and letting anybody into the
country wants to come in compromising
our national security because we have no
idea who's in here compromising our
elections because you're just flooding
the country with foreign aliens who will
then presumably if they have children
those children will get birthright
citizenship they'll be able to vote I
mean it creates so many social problems
but still the Conservatives are
compassionate we say 100,000 children we
don't want that we want to cut off the
flow of migrants to come into the United
States maybe we need to put some
National Guard troops on the southern
border with Mexico we need to
renegotiate certain deals with Mexico so
that they can cooperate with us better
on the immigration issue you know it's a
serious issue we should take it
seriously okay fine that was the first
tweet second tweet AFP is withdrawing
this story the author of the report has
clarified that his figures do not
represent the number of children
currently in migration related u.s.
detention but the total number of
children in migration related u.s.
detention in 2015 we will delete this
story they're not even hiding it anymore
they're not even hiding it so what with
that what that second tweet really says
is hold on hold on
we are withdrawing the story why are you
withdrawing the story because it's not
true well no it it was true but it was
true during the Obama administration and
so because it was true during the Obama
administration it makes the Democrats
look bad we will not only withdraw the
story we're deleting the
story we will delete the story why don't
you leave the story up it's a pretty
interesting story I was interested in
the story when it looked bad for
Republicans because it's an actual
problems you got to deal with but the
press won't let the stories stand when
it looks bad for Democrats that that
little incident breaking news
oh wait never mind it looks bad for
Democrats that tells you everything you
need to know about the mainstream media
they are not fair brokers in any way we
we know that we know that they slant
stories for the left we know that they
choose their coverage based on the left
but it goes even deeper than that if
they accidentally report on a story that
looks bad for the left they will they
will apologize for that and they will go
back and delete it you cannot trust a
word they are saying what do we do here
at the at the Michael Knowles show and
at the other Daily wire shows we put out
conservative commentary okay so we have
a perspective a political perspective
we're honest about our perspective and
we report on the news we interpret the
news of the day through that
conservative lens even knowing that even
know being honest about our perspective
we don't hide news that is bad for
conservatives I mean I opened my show
today with a story about why President
Trump was wrong to sign this law
yesterday just as an example but we do
that all the time because we're not
interested in just carrying water like a
bunch of hacks
okay we're interested in the reality of
our political situation in our cultural
situation and we're interested in
advancing a better culture and a better
politics okay and you don't do that by
ignoring reality and yet the so-called
objective journalists of the left or
doing precisely that they are not merely
slanted not merely by lit biased they
don't merely have a perspective they are
propagandist water-carrying hacks for
the left who will actually go back and
delete their own work if it accidentally
looks bad for their political puppet
masters it it is shocking even for me
and I spend a lot of time hanging the
media but that's pretty bad and I don't
think it's gonna work out for them this
is the other thing if any members of the
mainstream media are watching this use
this as an example if the media had
played their cards a little closer to
the chest if they had been a little more
cautious about this they would still
have some credibility but they've been
exposed repeatedly time and time again
look at the Epstein story George
Stephanopoulos I was talking to drew
about this yesterday in our another
Kingdom conversation George
Stephanopoulos is the war room
communications director for Bill Clinton
he covers up Bill Clinton's sex crimes
he silences the women that Bill Clinton
abused he then becomes the chief
political correspondent for chief
political anchor rather for ABC News ABC
News has footage leaked of one of their
anchors saying that the Jeffrey Epstein
story was killed at ABC what happens
when that story leaks ABC News rushes to
figure out what happened by silencing
the whistleblower they don't try to
they're going on trying to find the
whistleblower they're not going on
trying to find the person who actually
killed the Epstein story they are so
unbelievably corrupt that now they don't
have credibility I mean in that Conan
video where President Trump has the dog
in the Rose Garden he's joking and he
says to the reporters by the way if you
open your mouths Conan is trained to
attack you so watch out and everyone
laughs at this because we hate the press
we hate them we hate that they lied to
us night after night after night one of
the constant applause lines that Trump
gets it is very large rallies is when he
says look back there those are the fake
news they're gonna smear us cuz they're
the scum of the earth and people cheer
people applaud and it's not just
conservative Republicans its
independence too who are fed up with the
lies if they had just played it a little
better they would have credibility now
they have no credibility in fact the
opinion people on the left and the right
in my mind have a lot more credibility
than the so called objective mainstream
media outlets Rachel Maddow and The
Young Turks and whoever else voxcom have
a lot more credibility because at least
they're honest about their
perspective I can know what it is going
in and sometimes not always but
sometimes they'll even report on stories
that are not wonderful for the left the
same cannot be said certainly of AFP
news certainly of ABC news certainly of
CNN and all of those I mean another
example Bloomberg Bloomberg major media
company not to be confused with the
former mayor of New York who's now
running for president even though
they're the same thing Bloomberg media
because Mike Bloomberg is running for
president says that they are not going
to investigate Democrats the idea being
that Mike Bloomberg is running in the
Democratic presidential primary and so
that he's not going to use his organ to
investigate his primary opponents but
Bloomberg media didn't have to put out
that statement
Bloomberg media already doesn't
investigate Democrats Bloomberg media
already carries water for Democrats and
help and end attacks Republicans there's
no there's nothing's going to change and
that's true not just a Bloomberg it's
true of all of the other ones also by
the way if if the whole idea here is
that Mike Bloomberg is not going to use
his news organ to investigate his
political opponents why not also promise
not to investigate Trump they're not
going to do that because the media are
done even pretending to be in any way
objective speaking of Mike Bloomberg the
president Trump got some good news from
him
his campaign manager went on CNN to
explain his candidates he explained the
campaign strategy and he admitted that
right now President Trump is winning
listen he's obviously the news today
yeah you know your guest before this
talked about president chaos and and
obviously Mike's gonna is gonna comment
on it listen Mike is getting in this
race because he thinks that Donald Trump
is an existential crisis and he thinks
he's on a path to victory and he's
getting into alter that dynamic he is he
is on a path to victory obviously
Democrats think this by the way that's
why other candidates are looking getting
in the race Deval Patrick that's why Tom
Steyer got into the race well my
Bloomberg's getting into the race that's
why Hillary is trying to get into the
race because they don't feel comfortable
with Joe Biden or people to judge or
even Elizabeth Warren they just don't
think that these are serious people
they think that at this moment Trump is
on a path to victory and I think that
they're right but if Mike Bloomberg is
supposed to be the great savior of the
Democratic Party unfortunately he
doesn't appear to think that himself
let's not forget Mike Bloomberg is 77
years old he's nine months older than
Joe Biden he can like make his way
around the stage you know you can get a
coherent English sentence out of his
mouth he in his behavior looks like he's
about 20 years younger than Joe Biden
but he's an older guy and he feels as he
admitted just this year that he is too
old to be the president I've assembled
the team all ready to go but at some
point you got to say look I would be 79
years old when I took office
people say well Ronald Reagan was 80
when he left yeah when he was 80 they
carried him out gaga really it's very
close out of me to exaggerated but
that's very close to being true to start
a 4-year job maybe an eight year job at
age 79 may not be the smartest thing to
do but I think if I thought I could win
I would have all right to start this
long job at age 17 I'm probably the
smartest thing to do if I thought I
could win I would run and he now
apparently does think he has a good
chance of winning which is why he's
running but he is old the one thing I do
notice about all these clips of him he
goes on later in that same interview to
make fun of bado or work as just a
nobody Mike Bloomberg does for all of
his kind of billionaire sophistication
he does have this edgy New York attitude
obviously if you put that edgy New York
billionaire up against Trump the edgiest
New York billionaire Trump is going to
eat them alive on stage but Bloomberg
does have a little bit of that New York
attitude Bloomberg now is out there on
the campaign trail he thinks he's gonna
at least have a good shot at the
Democratic nomination even though it
doesn't appear that he thinks he's he's
necessarily gonna beat the president he
goes out and gives his first major
campaign rallies see how excited you get
listening to Mike for America protecting
women's and LGBTQ rights supporting our
veterans and re-establishing America's
place in the world as a force
peace and stability but more than plans
I offer the leadership to turn plans
into reality to roll up my sleeves to
motivate our country to unite and
rebuild America and make it fairer and
better I'm ready to get to work so let's
get it on
that's why Mike Bloomberg finish talking
so they just two seconds of that very
quiet soft-spoken 77 year old man and
I'm just completely out amazing to
compare that to President Trump does
anybody really believe that Mike
Bloomberg is going to get on stage and
quietly talk about the same platitudes
that were sort of popular in the early
90s and that he's going to beat Donald
Trump who's the hippest guy in politics
not going to happen there's also a
physical aspect here which is that
obviously a man of a more diminutive
stature have been fairly successful
throughout history namely Napoleon for
instance but Mike Bloomberg is really
short I've met Mike Bloomberg I don't
remember what the event was in New York
and I was pretty astounded by how petite
he is and I'm not exactly a basketball
player okay but if you look online it
says Mike Bloomberg five-foot-eight that
is just a complete lie there was no
chance the guy's five foot eight I
toured over this man when I met him and
I'm not a particularly gigantic
individual so it's just not believable
that he is going to beat Trump and yet
Democrats and certainly his team think
that the field is so insufficient right
now that he might be the last best hope
if he's the last best hope of the
Democrats then I I wouldn't I wouldn't
hold their breath to would take the
White House in 2020 more good news from
President Trump from the Supreme Court
the Democrats have been trying to get
president Trump's financial records
they've been trying to get the financial
records to just add some icing to
impeachment because after all these
impeachment hearings they haven't really
gotten anything on him most of the
testimony just said yeah Trump
explicitly said we don't he doesn't want
to quid pro quo he didn't do anything
wrong no one can even explain exactly
what the crime is the president Trump
committed
so that it was really a flop for House
Democrats now they're trying to get the
financial records to say well you know
he underpaid his taxes or he had some
shady business deals so we got to
impeach him for that to the Supreme
Court eventually heard about this
question in the Supreme Court on Monday
yesterday delivered a major setback to
the house Democrats were trying to
impeach Trump because they blocked a
lower court decision that was going to
give them access immediately to
president Trump's financial records the
Supreme Court decided they put out a
one-paragraph order that put a pause on
that lower court ruling and it said the
president Trump gets to keep his
financial records for now now they're
going to have to keep arguing this
before the court but that's a major win
for president Trump not to put too fine
a point on it but there it would seem
that even in the house among the House
Democrats they're starting to crack a
little bit on impeachment because the
question is knowing what we know now
about President Trump's popularity about
president from support particularly
among non-white voters yesterday there
was an Emerson poll that backed up an
NPR Marist Poll that showed President
Trump had upwards of thirty four point
five percent support among black voters
that is record shattering in recent
memory for a Republican president he had
very high numbers among Hispanic voters
to is over 38% knowing that the
Democrats don't have anything in the
impeachment probe knowing that they're
not going to get the financials at least
anytime soon is it worth impeaching the
president some Democrats say no there's
a Michigan Democrat representative
Brenda Lawrence who is suggesting maybe
Democrats shouldn't impeach Trump maybe
they should choose a lesser measure like
censuring president Trump outright
condemning him for all the terrible
things that nobody can quite point out
that he did rather than impeaching why
because it would seem that the momentum
is with impeachment Pelosi didn't want
to impeach Trump but she was losing
control of her caucus and so she had to
finally go along with the more radical
members if they impeach Trump then it
goes to a trial in the Senate if it
to a trial in the Senate the Republicans
control that house that chamber if it
goes to a trial in the Senate you're not
going to see the key witnesses that the
Democrats wanted to bring up by the way
the key witnesses that the Democrats
wanted to bring up like Bill Taylor like
George Kent like Psalm hland
Gordon Psalm 'land all of those guys in
their testimony were pretty favorable
toward Trump some cases extremely
favorable toward Trump those aren't the
guys that the Republicans in the Senate
are going to call if impeachment goes to
trial
the Republicans in the Senate are gonna
call people like oh I don't know hunter
Biden to testify the Republicans in the
Senate are gonna call people like oh I
don't know
Eric cha ramela the alleged
whistleblower who had a lot of shady
contacts with a lot of prominent
Democrats like Joe Biden like John
Brennan like Adam Schiff who was running
the whole impeachment hoax in the house
it's gonna look really really bad for
Democrats if it goes to trial in the
Senate President Trump said please go to
trial and begging for it to go to trial
because in that case he'll very likely
be acquitted even Democratic analysts
are admitting this now and if he's
acquitted he could have a lot of
momentum going in to 2020 all of that is
pretty good news some people say this is
evidence of a broken political system
perhaps it is I mean we talked about it
at the top of the show today we have a
broken political system now because
we've lost sight of the moral order
we've lost sight of first of all how our
government works and how our government
is structured but at a deeper level
we've lost sight of the moral
foundations for politics
that is bad news we are dealing with a
political situation now that is pretty
off kilter however we've got to play in
the political realities that exist and
as they exist right now things are
looking pretty good for conservatives
good news something to be thankful for
as we head into Thanksgiving
we got another show tomorrow so don't go
anywhere don't get on your flights and
get in your cars and go eat turkey yet
we will have another one tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy bore
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel y
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by my core amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]